le pouvoir a-t-il un sexe et si oui
lequel documentaire signé Hélène riser
qui a osé jarré l'exercice du pouvoir et
qui a même scientifisé le sujet un film
audacieux qui pose bien sûr un certain
nombre de questions que nous allons nous
poser avec nos invités Michel
Alliot-Marie bienvenue le pouvoir vous
connaissez bien député pendant plus de
10 ans mère de Saint-Jean-de-Luz pendant
presque 7 ans député européenne
secrétaire d'État et bien sûr plusieurs
fois à la tête de ministère régalien
ministre de la Défense ministre de
l'Intérieur ministre de la Justice vous
avez également été ministre des Affaires
étrangères merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous Cécile Duflot bienvenue à vous
également directrice générale d'Oxfam
France vous connaissez aussi très bien
le monde du pouvoir de l'Intérieur à la
tête du Parti vert puis Europe Écologie
Les Verts vous avez été conseillé
régional ministre de l'Égalité des
territoires et du Logement député et
co-présidente du groupe écologiste à
l'Assemblée bienvenue à vous Bérengère
Bonte bienvenue le pouvoir vous
l'observez depuis plusieurs années et
notamment le pouvoir au féminin vous
êtes journaliste politique vous avez
vraiment publié Elisabeth borne la
secrète aux éditions de l'archipel on
peut aussi vous écouter tous les jours
sur France Info dans l'intrus de l'actu
chronique qui donne chaque soir un coup
de projecteur sur une personnalité qui
aurait pu passer sous les radars de
l'actualité les hambelles bienvenue à
vous également vous êtes journaliste et
éditorialiste politique vous avez fondé
le premier podcast politique qui donne
la parole aux femmes et qui propose un
regard féministe sur la politique vous
avez aussi publié plus de femmes en
politique point d'exclamation aux
éditions Pocket merci beaucoup à toutes
les quatre je voudrais d'abord que l'on
reste quelques instants sur la conquête
du pouvoir qui est un petit peu
différent de l'exercice du pouvoir il y
a peut-être des éléments que vous
contesterez dans ce documentaire dans
les démonstrations qui sont faites mais
il y a un fait qu'on ne peut pas
contester c'est qu'il y ait moins de
femmes que d'hommes qui osent se lancer
à la conquête du pouvoir Michel Ayou
Marie est-ce que conquérir le pouvoir a
été un sujet dans une autre histoire
personnelle est-ce que le fait d'être
une femme a été un sujet ou pas du tout
dans la conquête de vos mandats non ça
n'a pas été un problème du tout ça s'est
fait assez naturellement peut-être
est-ce que j'ai eu de la chance
d'arriver à un moment où la place des
femmes a commencé à être reconnue où les
choses étaient peut-être plus détendues
même s'il y avait bien entendu des
machos un peu partout mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est peut-être plus
difficile à vrai dire quand vous dites
les femmes qui
osent concret le pouvoir c'est pas oser
moi je ne dirais qui est en vie parce
que ça ça me paraît un problème majeur
les femmes n'ont pas forcément envie de
faire de la politique pourquoi non pas
parce qu'elles ont d'autres occupations
c'est pas ça le problème mais moi je
sais que je me suis heurté à plusieurs
reprises que notamment quand j'étais
présidentE du RPR j'étais élu comme
première femme présidente du RPR dans un
parti qui était dit machiste et sans qui
est aucune règle aucune loi cette époque
je me suis constituée une équipe
complètement paritaire et le problème
que j'ai eu c'était la réticence des
femmes à aller vers un milieu qui a la
réputation d'être extrêmement agressif
et peut-être est-il d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui encore à l'égard des
politiques plus qu'il ne l'étaient à
l'époque et donc là il y avait un manque
d'envie évident je dirais qu'il faut
aussi distinguer probablement selon les
lieux de pouvoir ça n'est pas la même
chose de convaincre une femme d'aller à
une mairie surtout dans un dans une
petite commune que de lui proposer de se
présenter un mandat de députés et vous
Cécile Duflot dans votre parcours à vous
et ce qui a eu un problème d'envie ou
ne pas oser y aller est-ce que vous avez
eu ce genre de sujet ou pas du tout
alors moi je suis vraiment de la
génération
de la parité j'ai commencé à dans une
organisation qui avait la parité dans
ses statuts et pour dire les choses très
simplement je me suis retrouvée à la
direction du parti parce que la motion
dans laquelle j'étais avait fait un
score plus important que prévu et il
fallait une femme en plus donc il
fallait aller vraiment céder ça c'est
qu'il fallait une candidate
une candidate mais vous auriez pu dire
non ou ne pas oser j'aurais pu dire non
je pense que j'avais pas vraiment
réalisé très précisément ce que ça
signifiait moi je suis pas du tout dans
une famille ou qui que ce soit elle fait
de la politique au contraire tout le
monde était très défiant donc j'avais
pas vraiment une représentation très
précise de ce que ça signifiait et
ensuite ensuite j'ai eu envie de façon
paradoxale au moment où ceux qui
m'avaient octroyé entre guillemets cette
place à partir du moment où j'ai
commencé à donner mon avis ont eu envie
de me virer et là ça m'a énervé et donc
ça a été par esprit de contradict
sursaut d'orgueil qui m'a fait gagner un
vote d'une voix et donc rester à la
direction de ce parti c'est ça en fait
le ébull histoires et puis ensuite oui
ensuite j'ai été mordu puis je pense que
parfois on a aussi
des sensibilités ou des des talents
enfin voilà moi je m'appelle Cécile
parce que ma mère voulait une fille
musicienne c'est la sainte patronne des
musiciens ça a foiré complètement mais
je devais avoir un truc où la politique
j'ai compris comment ça fonctionnait
mais je voudrais juste revenir sur le
fait que les femmes et on vit ou pas
il y a plein de choses autour de tout ça
mais ce qui est certain c'est que je me
suis donné comme règles de toujours
aller à la rencontre des jeunes femmes
qui se posent des questions sur
l'engagement et la première question
qu'elle pose toutes tout le temps c'est
comment c'est possible de concilier ça
avec sa vie personnelle jamais un homme
de 22 ans 23 ans va dire mais alors
comment ça va être possible de concilier
alors que toutes les femmes se posent
cette question
et puis elles ont peur aussi de l'image
que ça donne mais ça on en reviendra ça
dans le documentaire qui est vraiment
moi j'ai trouvé absolument super il y a
la face obscure c'est certaines femmes
qui ont pas envie d'avoir ce statut là
avec tout ce que ça enlève dans sa
représentation vis-à-vis des autres et
notamment dans sa vie personnelle et ça
c'est une réalité parce que
factuellement les chiffres sont là
donnés par la Direction générale des
collectivités locales 19,8% des mers
sont des femmes c'est moins d'un élu sur
cinq 20,2% des présidents des Conseils
départementaux sont des femmes c'est
toujours très peu 31 et 6% des
présidents de région sont des femmes
alors est-ce que les lecteurs français
est sexistes ou est-ce que les femmes
osent moins se lancer mais en gerbant je
peux rajouter un chiffre depuis le début
de la 5e depuis 58 vous savez combien de
femmes se sont présentées à la
présidentielle je compte pour un le fait
de cette présenter plusieurs fois 14
femmes pour 75 hommes et combien est-on
ont été en finale si je puis dire de
il y a et moi pour avoir fait une assez
longue enquête là-dessus il y a quelques
années
il y en avait notamment un certain
nombre qui de ces femmes qui qui
allaient à la bataille avec la certitude
et qu'elle ne gagnerait pas en été sur
une candidature de témoignages et on
n'est pas si loin de cette époque là
cette enquête là c'est il y a deux ans
donc en plus même quand elle se lance
elles sont persuadées qu'elles perdront
voilà alors incroyable pour pour
différentes raisons mais alors il y
avait effectivement des parties surtout
à gauche chez les Verts mais aussi au PC
et Arlette Laguiller clairement il
voulait une femme depuis le début elle a
fait si candidatures il voulait une
femme donc il y avait un certain nombre
de parties qui voulaient absolument une
femme mais dont les femmes vous dites
moi qui même mais Christiane Taubira m'a
dit ça il va jolie m'a dit ça non je
n'imaginais pas une seconde et très
Lucas
il est vrai aussi mais c'est vrai au
niveau du Parlement que très souvent
tous les cas dans mon parti mais pas
seulement c'est aussi parce qu'il n'y a
pas de chance de gagner que l'on
souhaite
mais peut-être aussi dans les exemples
que vous donniez actuellement pour la
présidentielle c'est probablement
beaucoup plus difficile dans un très
grand parti où il y a une véritable
chance d'accéder au pouvoir de mettre
une femme ça je pense que c'est une
vraie question que nous devons nous
poser bien sûr c'est le concept de la
falaise de verre d'ailleurs on l'a bien
vu notamment avec la candidature Dani
dalgo pour le Parti socialiste très
concrètement je pense que si en novembre
octobre novembre 2022 2021 pardon le
Parti socialiste avait été aux alentours
de 20 25% dans les sondages à mon avis
Bernard Cazeneuve serait sorti du bois
bien avant pas aujourd'hui ils ont bien
laissé faire parce qu'on savait très
bien que c'était peine perdu dans tous
les cas pour revenir aussi aux
techniques qui sont souvent employés par
les partis politiques vous disiez il y a
peu de chance en fait peu de chance
c'est parce que c'est organisé c'est une
stratégie on met des femmes sur des
circonscriptions qui ne sont pas
gagnables donc ça nous permet de
respecter les obligations en matière de
parité ce que certains partis par
ailleurs se refusent de faire mais ceux
qui décident tout de même de le faire
vont effectivement présenter 50% de
femmes typiquement pour législatives et
finalement on investir qu'un certain
nombre de pourcentages qui sont en
capacité de remporter aussi organisé
orchestré par des hommes bien sûr ah oui
des commissions des commissions
d'investiture sont composées d'hommes le
problème n'est-il pas aussi culturel et
directement liée à notre histoire dans
ce film Hélène Risser interroge une
professeur en sciences de la
communication qui semble tout dire
écoutez
la France se caractérise ou se
singularise en tout cas dans le concert
des nations et notamment des nations
européennes par une
par une propension particulière à
exclure les femmes du pouvoir et à faire
en sorte d'identifier le pouvoir au
masculin
on se rappelle notamment sous la
monarchie de la fameuse loi dite salique
qui a consisté à exclure les femmes du
trône et le résultat c'est que la France
a été le seul pays en Europe ou le mot
reine n'a plus désigné que les pouces du
roi
tout est dit là non c'est du faux ça
part de là en fait alors je pense qu'il
y a effectivement
un lien avec cette représentation là
qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs si on regarde
les débats sur l'accession aux
responsabilités des femmes il y a deux
moments dans au 20e siècle où en fait on
aurait pu aller beaucoup plus vite
notamment au monde la Première Guerre
mondiale où les femmes ont assumé et on
voit tout ce qui est mis en oeuvre pour
ramener les femmes chez elles avec une
pression familialise sur le fait il faut
repeupler la France il faut faire des
enfants et faire sortir les femmes des
endroits de responsabilité donc il y a
eu aussi c'est pas seulement qu'il y a
un poids historique c'est qu'il y a eu
des freins et il y a certains qui se
sont employés à mettre ses freins pour
éviter que les femmes accèdent à des
responsabilités même le débat sur le
droit de vote des femmes il est acquis
par amendement c'est vraiment un
amendement de faire non grenier et
lui-même quand il défend son amendement
on lui objecte que il y a encore
beaucoup d'hommes prisonniers de guerre
donc il faudrait mieux qu'elle ne vote
pas dès le lendemain de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale dès la fin de la guerre
et lui dit non pas d'inquiétude les
femmes qui vont voter elles vont voter
comme aurait voté leur mari c'est-à-dire
que celui même qui défend le droit de
vote des femmes le fait avec un argument
d'un sexisme total mais c'est aussi
parce que c'est déstabilisant pour les
hommes je je il y a plein d'hommes quand
on quand on associe tellement la vie
l'identité le pouvoir avec la virilité
voir avec la capacité érectile je vais
dire les choses ben forcément quand
c'est une femme bah ça rend stress
beaucoup donc le fait de les éloigner ou
de les de les bousculer quand elles sont
en situation responsabilité ou pas les
respecter en fait c'est aussi une
fragilité
je suis entièrement d'accord avec cette
analyses finalement que les hommes ont
peur des femmes c'est ça la réalité et
ils ont peur en même temps de ne pas
être à la hauteur de ce que l'on a
entendu vous l'avez senti vous l'avez
observé oui bien sûr
de nombreuses reprises vous savez je
suis d'une famille qui est à la fois
Gauliste et traite de l'avant-garde si
je veut dire pour cela j'avais une
grand-mère qui a été infirmière majeure
pendant la guerre de 14 qui finissait
les opérations quand les chirurgiens
c'était mis à l'abri j'ai une mère qui
m'a toujours expliqué ce qu'un homme
faisait pour une femme pouvait le faire
c'est tout naturel et en plus on avait
quelque chose en plus et ce que j'ai
constaté effectivement c'est que les
hommes sont probablement un peu
prisonniers de cette image où on attend
deux qu'ils soient protecteur c'est ça
la vieille image qui est victime d'un
système qu'ils ont eux-mêmes mis en
place c'est tout à fait ce que je pense
et ce que je crois effectivement c'est
que ils ont peur des femmes ils se
méfient des femmes combien de fois en
politique alors pour le coup
je vu l'idée d'un soupçon finalement
elles ont quelque chose qui vont leur
permettre d'arriver avant nous une des
choses qui m'a beaucoup amusé quand je
suis arrivé comme ministre de la Défense
donc je venais de prendre mes fonctions
non j'étais pas très très fier j'ai
jamais fait de service national etc
première parce que c'est pas le fait
d'être une femme c'est le fait d'être la
première et je suis rentré dans le
bureau où tous les chefs d'état-major
est-ce qu'on appelle les grands
subordonnés étaient là et je voyais
leurs yeux et j'avais l'impression qu'il
se disait mais qu'est-ce qui nous arrive
et finalement quelques années plus tard
le chef d'état-major l'époque bah dit
écoutez nous quand on vous a vu arriver
on s'est demandé qu'est-ce que le
Président de la République nous faisait
et on s'est dit mais comment une femme
va-t-elle pouvoir décider bon il a
ajouté au bout de quelques heures on
avait compris mais c'est pas ça le
problème
vous avez cela et quoi que ce soit quand
je me suis présenté ce que ce que disait
style Duflot tout à l'heure m'amuser
parce que quand je me suis présenté la
présidence du RPR où le nombre de
personnes qui ont dit une femme à la
présidence du RPR se parti censé être
machiste ça ne marchera jamais mais
pourquoi est-ce que j'y suis allé ça
m'amuse un peu j'aimais pas ce qui se
passait mais surtout un de mes collègues
que je ne citerai pas naturellement a
fait passer
un mail dans lequel enfin c'était texto
oui à l'époque dans lequel il disait
mais une femme ne peut pas être la tête
du RP et puis Michel Alliot-Marie et
c'est d'ailleurs Chanel parce que si
j'en ai jamais porté bon j'ai dit
prescription elle pourrait être je lui
ai dit c'est comme ça et ben je serai
président de plus à faire c'est comme ça
que finalement ça c'est fait il y a
quelque chose d'intéressant dans ce que
dit cette spécialiste Bérengère bon
c'est aussi que ça semble être un
problème typiquement français
lorsqu'on dézoome un peu on s'aperçoit
que la plupart des pays du monde ont eu
une femme élue présidente juste en
Europe déjà on a préparé une petite
carte mais l'Autriche la Croatie
l'Estonie la Finlande la Géorgie la
Grèce la Hongrie l'Irlande l'Islande la
Slovaquie et j'en passe la liste est
immense en Asie en Amérique latine en
Afrique il y a eu plein de femmes lu
présidente et même dans des pays où on
pourrait considérer que les droits des
femmes ne sont pas respectés et la
France a une particularité quand même
dire que la France est un vieux pays
macho
oui probablement en partie moi j'étais
d'ailleurs frappé j'ai rarement entendu
aussi clairement que dans ce dans ce
documentaire cette particularisme
français
il y a quelques années il y a une enfin
depuis quelques années d'ailleurs il y a
une chercheuse britannique qui a
beaucoup travaillé sur la candidature
sur les femmes on politique en France
elle a fait ses étudiants à Sciences Po
en France et les repartie travailler
depuis 20 ans en Angleterre mais elle
avait notamment beaucoup décrypté la
candidature de Ségolène Royal en 2007 et
alors je vais aller en sens de ce que
vous dites c'est à dire que elle est
assez critique sur la façon dont les
journalistes questionnaient l'autorité
ou l'autoritarisme
l'empathie ou pas d'une candidate enfin
j'ai des on cherchait l'empathie de ces
Nicolas Sarkozy enfin où sa capacité de
décision mais c'était vrai des
journalistes c'est vrai et c'est très
elle a vraiment tout le vocable de
l'époque etc c'est très intéressant
c'était vrai aussi des instituts de
sondage qui donc du coup questionner
d'une façon particulière disons-le aussi
c'est vrai quand même dans les partis
politiques et tous les candidats
Ségolène Royal la première quand elle
vous raconte que Michel Rocard est venu
la voir après la primaire en lui disant
je sais que tu as gagné mais on est
d'accord ça va être moins con voilà
c'est aussi simple que ça donc il y a il
y a alors est-ce que c'est un
particularisme français moi je c'est
assez frappant de voir quand même c'est
les autres pays ont élu des femmes
présidentes les agents il y a
effectivement un héritage français et
qui s'explique notamment par le fait que
les femmes ont accédé on parle beaucoup
de droits de vote on oublie le droit
d'élégibilité les femmes ont accédé
effectivement en 1945 à la possibilité
de pouvoir voter mais aussi à la
possibilité de pouvoir être élu donc il
est vrai que quand on regarde la majeure
partie de nos voisins européens et
notamment les pays scandinaves et aussi
les pays d'Europe de l'Est on constate
effectivement que les femmes ont déjà pu
accéder à ces fonctions électives que 50
ans en moyenne après d'autres États donc
il y a un retard assez important qui est
aussi il faut le lier au combat en fait
féministe ça c'est aussi important de
revenir là-dessus parce que ce n'est pas
venu du jour au lendemain alors bon très
bien effectivement la droite finalement
à permis en quelque sorte aux femmes de
pouvoir être élu mais c'est aussi parce
qu'on pensait que ça allait favoriser la
droite puisque effectivement les femmes
étaient censées voter comme comme leur
époux et donc beaucoup de cynisme voilà
donc finalement c'était un peu une
stratégie politique je ne suis pas
totalement convaincue de la sincérité de
cette mesure mais enfin c'est fait et
nous sommes là aujourd'hui donc tant
mieux et ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui
c'est que en France il y a cette
particularité effectivement d'avoir une
classe politique relativement machiste
mais ce n'est rien à voir avec la
société on me disait et c'est d'ailleurs
Edith Cresson qui me disait pendant nos
entretiens que le milieu politique est
bien plus machiste que la société
française donc ça c'est très important
il faut aussi dissocier ça par contre là
où je pense qu'il y a quand même quelque
chose qui revient dans tous les pays
presque du monde moi j'ai eu la chance
de travailler dans pas mal de pays au
Brésil au Cambodge etc ce que j'ai pu
constater c'est que n'importe quel dans
n'importe quel pays on associe pouvoir
et domination et d'ailleurs ça revient
dans le documentaire c'est ce qui est
présent dans le documentaire ce n'est
pas spécifique à la France c'est quelque
chose que l'on voit de partout c'est à
dire que la domination égale pouvoir
international d'ailleurs l'étude est
internationale et montre même qu'en
Norvège c'est aussi c'est au Liban en
France et en Norvège montre que c'est
que c'est quelque chose que l'on perçoit
encore donc il y a une urgence absolue à
déconstruire en fait cette relation
entre pouvoir et domination il reste
quand même cette question de savoir
pourquoi effectivement tant de pays vous
les avez cités ont mis des femmes
présidentes tout en haut de sommet de
l'État et chez nous c'est quand même
très très compliqué 30 ans après des
cressons finalement on a une première
ministre c'est une autre on dit tous les
15 jours qu'elle va sauter enfin
honnêtement par un homme c'est même pas
une
excuse-moi
une question de volonté politique et moi
je me souviens très bien
sentiment au moment où on parlait de la
parité moi j'étais contre le texte sur
la parité et notamment son inscription
dans la Constitution parce que je suis
furieuse quand je vois une femme
compétente qui était écartée au profit
d'un homme incompétent mais je trouve
que l'inverse nommait un homme
incompétent un homme et une femme
incompétente à un homme compétence ça me
pose réellement problème
alors il y a eu de bons résultats je
vais pas dire le contraire mais sur le
principe je suis plutôt du côté
d'Elizabeth Badinter où je trouve que
c'est c'est pas ça mais je me souviens
effectivement j'en ai discuté avec
quelqu'un qui fut premier ministre il y
avait qui j'ai de nombreuses discussions
qui pour notre partie disait qu'il était
favorable à la loi et je lui dis mais
attendez c'est une question de volonté
si vous décidez vous effectivement que
ce sont des femmes qui seront candidates
dans les circonscriptions où on va
gagner vous réglez le problème et sa
réponse ça a été mais j'ai besoin d'un
texte parce que je n'aurais pas le
courage de me poser à ceux qui sont sur
le terrain voilà mais c'est ça le
problème on a cour un texte parce qu'il
y avait pas la volonté politique et le
courage politique d'assumer ce qu'on
veut donc moi j'étais une jeune femme
qui était contre la loi sur la parité
parce que je me disais c'est quand même
pas juste c'est pas normal et après on
va dire que si on a des postes c'est
parce que etc sauf que sans ça ça ne
marche pas ça ne marche pas il faut dire
la vérité et il faut dire en revanche
que c'est une loi qui est qui est un
vrai effet dans la durée c'est-à-dire
que les écolos qui ont mis dans leur
statue pas exactement en 84 mais peu de
temps après les la parité à tout niveau
d'instance donc de manière obligatoire à
l'époque où moi je suis rentrée donc
dans tout début 2000 quand il y avait
des instances qui n'étaient pas régie
par les statues très vite la commission
électorale il pouvait y avoir que des
mecs très facilement les secrétaires
régionaux c'était
80% des hommes mais au bout de 30 ans de
fonctionnement paritaire ou fil du temps
ou des femmes ont dû du coup
plus avoir des responsabilités de
manière automatique il y a autant de
secrétaires régionaux femmes que
d'hommes etc donc j'ai résolu ce cette
espèce de Dilemme par une phrase que
j'aime beaucoup je connais pas son
auteur ou son autrice c'est dommage
c'est je n'aime pas les quotas mais
j'aime ce qu'ils produisent et c'est
exactement ça c'est et vous désirez
effectivement je suis d'accord avec vous
les quotas en russe c'était fait positif
donc enclencher une espèce de pièce dans
la machine pour que le mécanisme
exactement que le mécanisme puisse un
peu un peu ce se développer et et que la
et que la machine soit lancée néanmoins
et c'est en ça que je souscrit ce que
vous dites madame Ali Marie parce que
s'il n'y a pas de volonté politique
derrière les choses sont en capacité de
reculer c'est-à-dire que en 2022 pour la
première fois en France nous avons connu
un recul du nombre de femmes à
l'Assemblée nationale la parité n'est
plus un thème de campagne épluché les
les programmes aussi des partis
politiques le mot n'apparaissait
quasiment plus comme si le problème
était réglé et ça c'est gravissime parce
que le résultat c'est que nous avons
aujourd'hui moins de femmes à
l'Assemblée nationale donc il faut
certes des mécanismes juridiques
législatif voire constitutionnel comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui en France et il
faut par ailleurs une véritable volonté
politique et une autre question qui peut
paraître dérangeante qui est posée dans
le film c'est lorsque les femmes ont le
pouvoir est-ce qu'elle exerce
différemment des hommes ou est-ce que
c'est une aberration de le penser les
deux femmes mères du documentaire
montrent en tout cas qu'il y a une
rupture dans la façon d'exercer leur
mandat plus collectif plus accessible
plus horizontale c'est ce qui ressort
même visuellement de l'expérimentation
menée par Hélène Risser dans le film
c'est vrai qu'on regarde un extrait
qu'on en parle après
de grands Poitiers rendre des comptes la
vision verticale du chef qui connaît
tout n'est pas la tasse de thé de nos
cobayes politiques ce que confirme cette
petite expérimentation
[Musique]
à la fin de l'interview dans le bureau
panoramique des maires de Biarritz nous
avons demandé à mayder à rosti de nous
montrer comment elle habite cet espace
qu'elle a mis à ses couleurs
étonnamment la première pause du pouvoir
qu'elle a prise a été d'enlever ses
escarpins pour se mettre dans le canapé
avec sa pile de dossier
et quand est arrivé le rendez-vous de
travail elle est allée s'installer
autour de la table ronde moins formelle
que le bureau
et juste après ce passage la mère de
Poitiers nous dit que ça portait
toujours ouverte que ce qu'elle préfère
c'est boire des cafés avec ses collègues
pour échanger évidemment sur le fond des
idées mais en gèrement de vous en avez
observé beaucoup des femmes qui ont le
pouvoir et qui ont eu le pouvoir est-ce
qu'il y a une façon différente d'exercer
le pouvoir chez les femmes c'est l'un
des grands d'une des grandes forces de
documentaires précisément moi j'ai
rarement vu sur la durée enfin
ça vaut ce que ça vaut et sans doute que
si on a deux secondes pour en parler moi
j'y trouve que je me suis un peu
renseignée sur la façon en prévision de
cette émission dans ça se passait à
Poitiers on me dit quand même qu'il y a
beaucoup de com dans l'idée de dire on
est dans du collaboratif oui Poitiers en
commun c'était formidable sauf qu'à
enfin à l'épreuve des faits ça bloque
énormément de décisions alors elle elle
cherche de fait à fonctionner comme elle
s'était engagée à le faire mais je sais
qu'elle voulait par exemple tétoniser
une artère le faubourg de point royal de
de Pont-Neuf pardon à Poitiers
elle a concerté ça a bloqué et tout est
colocalé à la fin elle se retrouve
finalement réintroduire les voitures ce
qu'elle regrette amèrement en off mais
qui voilà quel exercice
de manière générale on peut dire
puisqu'on est un pouvoir différemment ou
pas
j'en suis pas malheureusement j'en suis
pas si c'est ah d'accord mais c'est
intéressant non non mais ne regrettez
pas parce que non mais
parce que bien sûr c'est beaucoup plus
collaboratif c'est beaucoup plus doux
c'est beau c'est c'est c'est faire une
rigoureux etc mais tout le monde est
beaucoup plus heureux c'est pas le cas
et en fait c'est plus une question de
personnalité sincèrement que donc
on rêve tout de pouvoir voilà constater
ça mais si on parle d'Elisabeth borne à
ce moment que j'ai quand même un cas que
j'ai bien bien examiné il y a une dureté
chez cette femme qui est voilà beaucoup
d'hommes n'ont rien à envier à cette
façon de faire malheureusement oui moi
je reviens à ce que vous disiez au tout
début de notre rencontre lorsqu'on
disait nos généralisons pas parce
qu'effectivement il peut y avoir des
choses différentes mais qui tiennent
aussi aux personnalités alors c'est vrai
que ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que l'histoire n'est pas la
même c'est à dire que les hommes sont
probablement depuis beaucoup plus
longtemps dans des postes ou finalement
il y a un certain nombre de codes qu'ils
ont assimilé les femmes venant de
l'extérieur et souvent d'autres
expériences parce que si vous regardez
fois qu'on en a assez peu parlé mais la
carrière des hommes en général il
commence très tôt à faire de la
politique les femmes commencent beaucoup
plus tard après une autre expérience
après d'autres rapports de singer les
hommes aussi dans leur façon d'exercer
le pouvoir moi comme ça moi je ne crois
pas mais en revanche vous avez un
certain nombre de femmes prenez deux
énarques homme et femme ils ont beaucoup
plus de points en commun que si vous
prenez deux personnes venant d'autres
expériences et que vous mettez ensemble
donc je pense que c'est plutôt
l'histoire personnelle qui compte et ce
que l'on a pu faire avant les femmes
donnaient dans une campagne électorale
Cécile dufaule c'est bien le marché
c'est un incontournable nous avons
l'habitude de faire le marché et on fait
le marché avec notre panier en même
temps qu'on fait de la politique et un
jour j'ai eu cette remarque en plein
marché de Saint-Jean-de-Luz et d'une
commerçante qui dit ah ben vous vous
prenez comme d'habitude elle se tourne
vers mon adversaire qui était là à dire
ah bah tiens c'est la première fois
qu'on vous voit excellent la campagne
était faite c'était parfait etc mais
c'est aussi pour répondre justement à la
façon de faire c'est vrai que il y a des
différences qui viennent de l'origine
mais qui sont aussi probablement plus
des différences de personnalités que des
différences de genre moi je crois
quelque chose de très particulier
je crois pas du tout effectivement sur
le fait qu'il y ait un éternel féminin
etc pas du tout du tout et que les
femmes soient plus douces tout ça c'est
pas vrai mais il y a une grande
différence c'est quand un homme gagne
une élection ça y est il est chef quand
une femme gagne une élection on va voir
ce qu'on va voir on va voir si elle est
capable ça c'est très différent mais ça
ça vient des autres pas d'elle
évidemment que ça vient d'elle aussi
parce que en revanche et ça c'est ce que
mon très bien tout le reste du
documentaire c'est que les petites
filles sont socialisées et alors même en
Norvège moi c'est ce qui m'a fait un peu
vide voilà je me suis dit mince et ça va
ça va peut-être prendre 150 ans son
socialisés pour douter pour pas être sûr
mais ce qui est compliqué et il y a un
impensé je sais pas qui photographes
documentaire là-dessus c'est quand vous
êtes une femme en politique il y a deux
handicaps structurels qui sont à
l'intérieur de vous c'est la
culpabilisation sur votre rôle de mère
quand vous avez des enfants kiné jamais
le cas mais ça vaut pour la vie
professionnelle un homme de 35 ans qui a
3 enfants un recruteur va se dire ah bah
c'est bon en gros c'est pas un coureur
de jupons il est posé il a une famille
c'est bien une femme de 35 ans qui a
trois enfants on va se dire ah mince
elle va se taper tous les trucs médicaux
et encore plus tabou encore plus tabou
oui bien sûr et donc on se dit dans 6
mois exactement
encore plus tabou la situation dans les
couples hétérosexuels c'est très
difficile les femmes sont habituées
depuis des milliers d'années à être la
femme de à être un pas derrière à être
la reine voilà donc d'avoir un statut de
femme de l'inverse n'existe pas ce qui
fait que c'est très compliqué moi ce qui
m'a beaucoup beaucoup marqué c'est une
interview du mari de Valérie Pécresse
dans Paris Match au moment où elle lance
sa campagne et il dit mais il y a pas de
problème moi je la soutiens enfin il est
super il dit je m'occuperai de la
cuisine et des enfants les enfants ils
ont tous plus de 20 ans j'espère qu'ils
ont pas besoin de papa pour leur faire
le dîner quand même mais intuitivement
lui il s'est mis dans un dans un dans
des codes de ce que doit être la femme
pour dire non mais elle est normale la
preuve moi je suis une femme normale et
et parallèlement les femmes savent bien
elles-mêmes si elles se le disent pas à
quel point c'est compliqué et ça c'est
l'eau tabou c'est le nombre de divorces
le nombre de de fracas privés des vies
personnelles des femmes le prix à payer
qui est très élevé qui est qui peut être
un frein qui a fait arrêter certaines et
qui aussi fait que les gens ont du mal à
vous imaginer purement chef parce que du
coup ils se disent ah mais donc si moi
je devais obéir à ma femme et c'est
aussi pour ça que je pense que certaines
femmes politiques jouent un autre rôle
une autre partition pour montrer ok je
suis chef mais je suis cool vous
inquiétez pas je vais pas vous castrer
et donc il y a une intégration de ces
stéréotypes là qui peut être compliqué
parce que pour beaucoup de femmes qui
commencent leur maman la mienne quand je
lui ai annoncé que j'étais devenu chef
des écolos elle m'a dit mais comment tu
vas faire avec les petits mais tout de
suite elle m'a pas dit bravo elle m'a
dit mince et et c'était et en plus je
sais qu'elle m'aime et tout ça et ça il
y avait pas de trucs tordu mais parce
qu'on est tellement élevé comme ça et
que du coup il faut chaque matin se
bagarrer contre ce sentiment le temps
nous manque malheureusement parce que
c'est passionnant j'ai une dernière
question pour vous toutes et si c'est
possible une question rapide êtes-vous
optimiste quand même est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que les choses
changent sont en train d'évoluer dans le
bon sens et en faveur des femmes et à
chambre alors je reviens peut-être juste
avant sur quelque chose d'assez
important qu'on appelle on n'a pas dit
c'est le fait que on renvoie encore aux
femmes cette c'est ce que vous disiez
c'est incapacité à gouverner c'est
incapacité à faire cette illégité qu'on
leur renvoie sans cesse et
l'incompétence aussi c'est à dire qu'on
dit constamment aux femmes vous n'êtes
pas incompétente etc etc donc moi ce que
j'ai constaté en écrivant ce livre c'est
que ces femmes là pour ceux pour qu'on
leur enlève cette espèce de couche qui
leur colle à la peau qui est celle de
l'incompétence et de l'illégitimité
pardon se force à faire beaucoup plus
que ce qu'on leur demande donc en
réalité les femmes je pense sont
infinies plus compétentes que les hommes
en politique et bon voilà et ça ça me
donne de l'espoir et je pense que c'est
quelque chose de positif c'est pour ça
qu'il faut plus de femmes en politique
moi je crois que la clé elle est dans
l'éducation de de des petits garçons et
des petites filles peut-être encore plus
des petits garçons
et parents qui nous regardent quoi c'est
c'est c'est ce sera vrai ça aura ça sera
long hein mais je pense que on s'en
sortira pas autrement que par ça parce
que honnêtement moi de tout ce que je
constate moi ça me rend pas très très
confiante les les tous les présidents de
parti vous disent à quel point c'est
compliqué quand même de faire des
disparitaires il y a vraiment il rame un
peu alors pour les européennes ils se
disent ah bah oui mais si je suis je
suis je me fais lire à l'Europe je
pourrai pas le problème des enfants etc
revient toujours il y a quand même
énormément de de signaux mais pas très
pas très positif quand je vois Valérie
Pécresse qui est obligé de faire une
grosse voix et de faire un meeting
absolument masculin et bah c'est quand
même déprimant et pourquoi si on veut
déconstruire tout ça j'aime pas trop ce
mot mais bon ça passe par par
l'éducation de de la génération d'après
de celle de l'actuel là qui va qui va
progressivement avoir un regard
différent surtout ça à la fois sur le
rôle des hommes et des femmes il s'agit
pas de que les hommes non plus ni
s'écrase ni voilà chacun doit pouvoir
mais ça passe vraiment par l'éducation
et c'est fondamental
les mêmes réflexe que ceux qui ont pu
exister dans le passé de pas le dire
parce que faut pas abîmer l'image de etc
etc et donc effectivement les choses
changent très très tôt elle change dans
l'enfance elle change dans le fait que
moi ma fille m'a raconté une histoire
exceptionnelle ils avaient décidé que
les garçons n'avaient pas le droit de
monopoliser la cour pour jouer au foot
et que donc il pouvait pas empêcher les
filles de venir jouer au foot très bien
ça avait été annoncé à tout le monde
tout ça c'est l'école primaire ben ma
fille a été très mécontente parce qu'en
fait les garçons avaient inventé une
nouvelle règle ok les filles ont droit
de jouer dès qu'on a marqué trois buts
elle me dit et à chaque récré il
marquait que deux buts et donc il y a
une résistance qui est quand même hyper
hyper forte mais peut-être
et à cause des femmes qui ont été les
premières il y a pour des jeunes femmes
des modèles d'identification qui
existaient beaucoup moins et du coup ça
rend les choses quand même plus facile
de se dire pour moi aussi c'est possible
et c'est plus aux femmes que je fais
confiance finalement que que aux hommes
pour
oser permettre l'accession
responsabilité et je pense que peut-être
que les quotas protégeront les hommes
mais surtout que libérer les hommes de
ce virilisme extrêmement toxique et
néfaste pour eux ce sera aussi une
conquête du féminisme pour la politique
aussi alors pour le coup si j'allais un
peu plus loin on fera pas face aux
dérèglement climatiques à une nécessité
de coopération internationale et
planétaire avec les codes de la
politique à l'ancienne où chacun joue au
petit chef et on s'arrêtera là merci
merci beaucoup à toutes les quatre
d'avoir participé à cet échange merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis comme chaque
semaine et de nous être très fidèles à
bientôt sur Public Sénat merci
[Musique]